le pacs l'eau vide n'est pas le nom
d'une nouvelle bibliothèque
iker mais celui de la nouvelle arme de
pfizer contre le kobe de 19 l'agencé
européenne des médicaments vient de
donner son feu vert pour son utilisation
au sein de l'union européenne
un enthousiasme certain point que la
france a réservé 500 mille doses pour
2022 et quelques milliers d'entre elles
devraient arriver dans les prochains
jours l'agencé européenne des
médicaments a recommandé d'autoriser
pacs au vide pour le traitement du kobe
19 chez les adultes qui n'ont pas besoin
d'oxygène supplémentaire et qui
présentent un risque accru que la
maladie deviennent graves alors qu'est
ce que le pacs le vide exactement il
s'agit d'un médicament antiviral à
prendre par voie orale et qui peut être
prescrite par un médecin généraliste
son objectif le même que celui du vaccin
éviter les formes graves du virus il est
recommandé de le prendre dès que
possible après un diagnostic positif au
kobe de 10,9 au maximum dans les cinq
jours suivant l'apparition des symptômes
le mécanisme d'action du pacs le vide
laisse espérer une efficacité maintenue
sur les différents variant y compris
omicron des données préliminaires in
vitro suggère en effet que les variants
préoccupons qui circulent actuellement
sont sensibles aux traitements un
médicament destiné aux personnes âgées
ou immunodéprimées ou considérés comme
très à risque et pour qui la vaccination
ne s'est pas montré suffisamment
efficace sauf que voilà il est contre
indiqué chez les personnes souffrant
d'une insuffisance hépatique ou d'une
insuffisance rénale sévère la haute
autorité de santé pointe aussi le risque
important d'interaction médicamenteuse
pour les patients qui prennent un autre
traitement et il faut dire que la liste
des médicaments et molécules qui ne
doivent pas être pris en même temps que
pax le vide est longue le risque
d'effets indésirables graves concernent
aussi bien des neuroleptiques que des
analgésiques des anti arythmique des
antihistaminiques des médicaments
anticancéreux les anticoagulants des
antidépresseurs des anti-infectieux des
somnifères
antibiotiques ou encore les thérapies de
substitution de la romaine thyroïdiennes
c'est aux médecins qu'il revient
d'apprécier avec son passion les
contre-indications médicamenteuse à
l'utilisation de pacs au vide ces
interactions nécessite la mise en place
d'un suivi rapproché bref vous l'aurez
compris c'est une pilule contre le kobe
19 destinés aux plus fragiles mais pas
trop quand même on n'y comprend pas
grand chose si ce n'est qu'il devrait
encore permettre de remplir les caisses
de pfizer son vaccin qui n'est pas
vraiment un vaccin puisque il n'accorde
pas d'immunité total mais protège des
formes graves a permis au groupe
pharmaceutique américain d'engranger 36
milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires rien qu'en 2021 et c'est loin
d'être fini puisqu'un autre vaccin plus
adapté a sonné crohn est en cours de
création et devrait être disponible pour
mars
nous espérons pouvoir arriver à un
produit qui protégera beaucoup mieux
contre les infections en particulier car
la protection contre les
hospitalisations et les cas sévères est
assez raisonnable avec les vaccins
actuels si vous avez eu la troisième
dose nous discutons actuellement avec
des responsables sanitaires du monde
entier pour décider de ce que nous
pensons être la meilleure stratégie pour
le rappel potentiel pour l'automne 2000
22 nouveaux médicaments nouveaux vaccins
dose de rappel si la crise du comique
perdure il semblerait que pfizer est
également de beaux jours devant lui